these are hiking boots These are
actually from Pharrell's line called
human race me and Pharrell made a lot of
music together for many many years it
was called the Nicktoons and my music
career let's say has stalled but he
makes a hell of a hiking boot hi GQ it's
me Nick Kroll these are 10 essential
items that I cannot live without on the
road
[Music]
good catch Nick these are uh Cape Cod
salt and vinegar potato chips I always
have some salt minis ready to go
wherever I am it's essential because you
want that
back of that they're potato chips but
because there's vinegar and this is
scientific because vinegar is like
it means that it kills all the fat and
that's science
usually my pre-show meal is like a
massive bowl of uh Bolognese it's like a
salad bowl size of pasta but if I don't
have time a bag of salt and Vinnies
that'll do the trick give me a little
something a little fuel
to get through the show and also you
can't beat that crunch
foreign
so this is GQ you know it's for stylish
folks it's a Lads mag so I thought I'd
show you probably the sexiest thing
about me and that's my toiletry bag my
dab kit I have a number of different
antihistamines that I have with me at
all times because I'm constantly having
massive allergic reactions because I
seem to be allergic to the world fellas
you know what the ladies love is
Savannah cream free of dyes fragrance
masking fragrance lanolin parabens and
from formaldehyde releasers then let's
get into the big boys folks eucrisa is a
non-steroidal cream that I put on my
face I've always been allergic but one
of the cool things about getting older
is that your body gets worse the things
that used to be slightly irritating you
become incredibly irritating to you
there's one item that I always have with
me when I'm on the road and that is a
spare tire it really is it's an
essential because you might get a flat
tire or you might find a bunch of babies
who want to do CrossFit can you imagine
like a baby just like doing that over
and over with a tire it's awesome it's
awesome to see babies taking care of
their bodies I want to see babies do
pull-ups I want to see babies push Tires
over and over I want to see babies do
burpees and I'm not talking about a cute
word for burps because babies do burpees
no I want to see babies jump up in the
air then get down do a push-up then
stand back up and do another jump in the
air
so every comedian has some version of
this like you have your notebook that
you jot notes in I always have one of
these I try to lose this like every four
to five months and then what I try to do
it's it's in my rider I was trying to
make sure to have at least three to four
uh broken pens to have with me to write
down notes for things jot down set lists
jot to new ideas these are always good
to have a pen that has literally nothing
inside of it and I'll be like this is
disgusting I can't believe I'm using
this pen to write down my notes like how
many hands have touched this pen and
within like 10 minutes of being
backstage in The Green Room I'm like hmm
so this is the notes from my from when I
was working on my hour for little big
boy now on Netflix it says your snacks
and then it's this problematic eater and
then an arrow and it says turn into
income whether that was a note for the
set or a note for my life it's worked
out pretty well and let's just say I
don't have to ask for salt and Vinnies
in the green room I can buy myself
[Laughter]
[Music]
when I'm not getting jacked up on coffee
all day long I do like to have tea I
really do drink a ton of Throat Coat
when I'm on tour before a show it helps
my voice but also when I'm doing voice
over animation I drink literally
pictures of throw coat all day long
because this voice
and then going right into this
and then we finish right back here takes
a toll on my throat so I like to get
that throw coat frankly to coat that
throat just a PSA if someone says I want
to coat your throat they probably don't
mean throw Coat tea you gotta have a tea
kettle around that's always on my rider
it's weird this one I guess belongs to
some guy named Max they let me use it
that's nice and this is matcha I love to
hate matcha who what is everybody doing
I know everybody loves matcha it tastes
like [ __ ] grass and not that good
kind you know what I'm saying both
I can do this it's legal not interested
in matchup
so when you go on tour you have a rider
what you don't realize is that the
artists pay for their Riders so forever
I'd be like yeah let's get cold cuts
let's get buried let's get it that's my
big extravagance is cold cuts you order
everything you could ever imagine and
then afterwards I realized like oh I was
paying for those in every venue because
I'd leave them behind one of the things
that I would have asked for at every
location was a yoga mat I want a yoga
mat wherever I go so that I can stare at
it and then not use it
so I brought this one from home you can
tell it's being used
oh look at that
that's crazy I guess an essential item
for me is my big mouth yoga mat
you guys should get one at home too I do
yoga I really actually love it I mean
down dog just for the pure sexual
undertones to it Warrior three I also
like and that's when I get banged out by
two dudes wearing Gladiator outfits what
else Mountain that's where you're just
sort of standing up straight but I
actually do I always feel better when I
do yoga
foreign
oftentimes when I can request a food
like if in my green room or if I'm doing
like a shoot for GQ Essentials I'll say
things that I want to have on the day
but really I just want to have so that I
don't have to do grocery shopping later
for example I always have asked for
organic eggs so that I can take those
home lobna labna is like sort of a
yogurty spread my son likes it with his
oatmeal and his fruit and berries uh
it's delicious these blueberries look
like they were grown on a farm on Mars
they're massive I do like to say
blueberries are nature's candy mmm
unwashed this is a
hmm
well this is a multi-use item as I've
gotten older I have found the zucchini
to be a very versatile vegetable and
you're the one who's being gross right
now
I do like uh some Ramen at home a
noodles in general Momofuku Dave Chang's
an old buddy of mine I get no money from
this but every now and again I get to go
to his house and he'll cook me and my
family lunch I do love uh oh a garlic
chili crunch oil
I really like to hike especially in Los
Angeles these are hiking boots These are
actually from Pharrell's line called
human race the problem with like hiking
shoes in general is they're always like
4 000 terribly ugly colors what I like
about these is they're just all black
they're very simple I would say Runyon
Canyon where I think is probably the
most known area to go hiking in La I
think a lot of influencers are there if
you ever watch people hiking on Runyon
Cannon you can see a lot of people with
real demons
[Music]
so there's obviously some stuff here
that's like kind of a joke but I have a
couple things that are actually really
important to me that I never leave home
without I have this locket and it says
always in my heart I have things that
are really close to me here
um one is
a picture of me and the other is
chocolate pretzels because I love
chocolate pencils I love how there's
chocolate on the outside
and if I have to eat the ones with dark
chocolate I will because I want to be
healthy but then the inside is like
crunchy and salty pretzels
and I just when I'm away from home I
want to remember how I can just polish
off an entire
huge bag of chocolate pretzels and not
even remember that I've eaten it so I
keep this Locker right right here I keep
it I keep this like here I keep
this is either a mini theragon or my
vibrating butt plug and I don't remember
which it is
that feels pretty good let me just just
do a quick check this mini theragon is
really nice because it's a little
quieter than the regular therabont so
you can be on the plane
you know what I mean and just
get to work I think we're all like
pretty uh stressed out and my wife told
me about fascia recently it's like the
wrapping paper to the present that is
our body we have to be better about
loosening that wrapping paper and so we
really got to keep our fascia loose
and we got a burp and we need to burp we
have to burp anyway thank you so much
for watching I hope you enjoyed a small
glimpse into my weird sad life on the
road